the new M3 14-in MacBook Pro is nice but
is it really worth spending the money
when you can buy an M1 MacBook Air and
both of these come with 8 GB of RAM well
today I'm going to make the choice easy
and I think a lot of you guys are going
to be surprised now we have done a ton
of testing over the last month and I did
not recommend this machine to people
because of that Ram the MSRP is
$1,600 but you can buy an M1 air for 750
bucks when you use that coupon code by
the way we have links below or for 660
you can get a refurbished one with a
3-month return policy and if you want to
upgrade to a terabyte of storage and 16
gigs of RAM that is 950 bucks compared
to 2 Grand if you upgrade this one
starting off with the designs this uses
the 14-in body that we've had for a
couple of years it's a little bit more
modern but the air is just so classic
with its wedge shape that I really like
and it's actually quite a bit more
comfortable for typing it is also
thinner and lighter and just a little
bit more enjoyable taking it around with
you now of course you do have the larger
bezels compared to the newer Max and you
do not have that Notch built in which by
the way let's compare the webcams this
is the 720p webcam and the built-in
microphones in the M1 MacBook Air as you
guys could see the quality isn't
terrible but it's not amazing either
it's a little bit fuzzy and then right
over there where we have that light it
is blown out and this is the 1080p
webcam in the studio quality microphones
in the M31 14-in MacBook Pro as you guys
see the light is not blown out I have a
lot more detail more contrast it's
definitely the better webcam but you
guys let me know about the difference in
microphone quality down in the comments
need access to all of your systems while
on the go well with pulseway you could
do just that access systems remote in
run scripts all of it from any device
closest to You Secure their special year
and specials with the link below now as
far as ports this is where the pro
starts to stand out first off we have
mag safe for charging and that is really
nice because it leaves your other ports
open compared to having to use USB
type-c now I often charge my MacBooks
with the USB type-c anyways cuz I have
that cable but that means that you just
have one Thunderbolt left over the 14-in
pro keeps its two Thunderbolt ports
opened up because you can use Mac safe
and you also get a full-size SD card
slot and an HDMI port as well now is
that worth spending a lot of extra money
personally I don't think so because for
about 50 bucks you can get a dongle yes
dongles kind of suck but you get a whole
ton of ports including ethernet usba a
you get a Micro SD card reader along
with a regular one HDMI and that gives
you more ports than you can get here I
would just keep it in your bag and by
the way I made a full video on the best
accessories for MacBooks so I'll have
that linked as well down below and now
let's talk about the displays the 14-in
one is larger and the aspect ratio is a
little bigger cuz you have that Notch
there and with that it actually gets
brighter 600 nits now compared to 400
now for normal use in a normal room it's
not that big of a deal but if you go
outside you will notice it now the
sharpness and detail are very similar
and if you're watching regular SDR
content it looks pretty much the same
but we have a mini LED display in here
and that means that it can get ultra
bright if you're viewing or working with
HDR footage so if you like watching new
movies that does make it nicer because
you don't get that greyness in the dark
if you're watching on this display and
with that you also have promotion so it
is also a little bit smoother I will say
that this is probably the biggest reason
I would want to get a 14in because you
get that nicer media and display
experience but not everybody cares about
that now with that we also have
differences in speakers this thing has
dual speakers with our little grills up
here but the 14in has a six speaker
system with dedicated woofer is go ahead
and take a listen to the
[Applause]
difference
start me and I'm sure you guys
absolutely could tell the difference we
just have such nice base in the system
that's why I say the whole media
experience is probably the biggest
reason to spend that extra money and now
we need to talk about the cooling
systems because the MacBook Air is
completely fanless compared to the 14-in
which has a single fan now all the
previous 14-in models had dual fans and
apple had to spend more money to
redesign it to make it worse because
when we tested this thing it heated up
really quickly and the fan was way
louder than other 14-inch MacBooks that
we have used so we're pretty much
comparing a completely silent machine 21
that if you start pushing it you're
going to get great performance but it is
going to run loud and that sucks because
Apple didn't really have to do that so
if you care about a completely silent
machine I you can go with the air and it
just doesn't even have a fan but with
that we need to talk about performance
and I'm going to start out with
geekbench just for an overall
performance and in single core the 14in
is about 32% faster we do have that
difference now this could apply to some
regular tasks but I've seen a lot of
people say that for emails web brow
browsing they can't really tell a
difference cuz both are very fast and
that's why people love the MacBook Air
now in terms of multicore we have a
difference of 38% and this is for your
tougher tasks now this is updated with
geekbench 6 so we are seeing that
difference here so when you start
pushing it that will come into play but
I'll give you guys another test in a
second but first I want to switch to
Graphics because that's where we have
the biggest difference with our
geekbench 6 metal score we have a
difference of 80
9% because this is the bent model you
can actually get better graphics in here
but you're paying more and so if you're
going to be doing something like doing
games or something that really hits the
GPU we do see that difference there now
in terms of throttling because it
doesn't have a fan in cine bench which
puts a full load on we have a difference
of
53% and that just shows that if you're
going to hit the CPU consistently for a
long time it will will slow down give
you a little bit more of a difference
but for photo editing with Lightroom the
crazy thing is we have a very small
difference between the machines I'm
talking about maybe 20 extra seconds of
waiting if you're rendering and when
you're actually editing the photos it's
not that different either so for most
people that are editing pictures unless
you're making money with it you're going
to be just fine and then for video
editors editing a 4K project with
various effects the export time is
identical with both systems cuz they
both have the same encoders so there's
no difference there now in the timeline
the smoothness will also be very similar
unless you pack in a crazy amount of
effects and that's where this one will
be better but it's slowed down by 8 gigs
of RAM um so that actually goes against
it now with that said about performance
I wanted to go back and talk about the
use case because a lot of people said
that this machine right here is for C
casual users even though it costs so
much and it's labeled a pro it is not
for pros especially with that 8 G of RAM
and I agree you need to spend 2,000
bucks if you want this to actually
perform the way it should and for the
people are going to walk into a store
and buy an 8 gig configuration for the
things that they do what most of those
people do the M1 MacBook Air is going to
do an excellent job it is still so fast
and much faster than your old Intel
MacBook or Windows machine um I most
people doing regular tasks are going to
be just fine when the MacBook Air came
out it blew people's minds as far as its
battery life it gets 8 to 10 hours but
the M3 Pro gets about 2 hours more in
real world mixed use because of the much
bigger battery and the newer chip that
is a little bit more efficient for light
tasks and then if you really push it it
will get worse um because you're using a
lot more power so in general the battery
life is a bit better with this one so to
conclude all of this personally for what
people are going to be buying this for
at that lower price without upgrading
anything most of those people will still
be completely fine and happy getting the
MacBook Air and saving a whole lot of
money and for people that come up to me
personally and ask they need just a
regular system it's going to run well
with great battery life I would say save
the money and get one of these or spend
400 bucks more and get a M3 Pro because
that one is so much faster than this if
you need that performance so thank you
guys for watching check out the links
down below to those other videos and
accessories click that Circle button to
subscribe check out one of those videos
right over there this has been Max and I
will see you in the next
[Music]
one